[Musique]
ça a commencé
excusez moi excusez moi j'avais pas
réagi sans le goût mon esprit était
accaparé seul avec la solitude
complètement ailleurs encore lorsque je
dis que mon esprit était seul avec la
solitude c'est comme quelqu'un qui va
vivre sur une île déserte qui dit y vit
sur une île déserte s'il y est l'île à
aller plus désertes de la même manière
je n'étais pas seul j'étais avec mon ami
la solitude mme amanpour mon enseignante
celle qui m'a jamais laissé tomber et
que j'ai du mal à comprendre
tout a commencé lorsque j'étais tout
petit comme ça je me levais j'avais
qu'un désir c'était de prendre du
plaisir
prendre du plaisir à donner du plaisir
aux autres alors je voulais être clown
ou cuisiniers j'ai commencé comme ça
tous les matins
oui à l'époque ça faisait plus faire que
maintenant mais prenaient du plaisir à
faire rire les gens
j'avais besoin de ce plaisir de cette
reconnaissance de regarder les autres et
de voir qu'il prenait du plaisir je les
recontacter eux mêmes et se permettait
d'avoir un contact avec moi même et puis
un jour vers l'âge de 6 ans je me suis
retrouvé à l'école assis avec des
camarades on m'a posé une feuille de
papier tiré de trait aux minutes cette
feuille de papier puis on m'a dit
maintenant tu vas arrêter de t'amuser tu
vas apprendre à travailler sérieusement
tu vas apprendre à lire et à écrire
je crois que ça a commencé là quelque
chose c'est complètement brisée à
l'intérieur de moi j'avais perdu quelque
chose on est de me mettre dans un cadre
le cadre de l'adulte le cadre de la
société qui me disait tu n'as pas le
droit de prendre du plaisir tu n'as pas
le droit d'être reconnu
tu n'as pas le droit d'être ce que tu es
tu dois être celui que tu penses que les
autres voudraient que tu sois alors j'ai
figé
devenu cuisinier j'ai travaillé pendant
des années on cuisine je donnais du
plaisir aux autres
14 16 18 heures par jour sans m'arrêter
pour leur donner du plaisir mais il y
avait un problème
moi je prenais plus de plaisir je me
suis battu contre ça quelque chose
m'appelait à l'intérieur de moi quelque
chose de sombre que je n'arrivais pas à
entendre qu'ils venaient me chercher et
qui me disait vas-y tu as le droit mais
non j'ai le droit de rien j'avais beau
combattre je ne pouvait être que celui
que je pensais que les autres vous dès
que je sois jusqu'à l'âge de 45 ans
j'avais figé j'avais combattu la flf je
fuis j'étais au bord du gouffre vous
savez ce moment dans la vie où y'a plus
rien de possible que vous alliez en
avant ou en arrière il ya plus de
solutions c'est le boom c'est la fin la
fuite
elle est pas compliqué comment faire
pour ne pas se réveiller demain
une fuite qui n'étaient pas réels pour
moi qui n'était pas possible alors un
jour avec ma femme et mes enfants on a
discuté et puis j'ai trouvé une solution
j'ai fui je quittais mon pays
ah ah
j'ai traversé la flaque suis venu au
québec j'étais persuadé que de l'autre
côté en fuyant l'herbe était beaucoup
plus verte
parce que cet environnement ce cadre
cette structure cette culture ne
convenait plus m'obliger à être celui
que je pense que les autres voudraient
que je sois est la problématique et est
resté je voulais voir à l'herbe plus
verte ailleurs mais je ne comprenais pas
tout ce que je comprenais c'est que je
ne trouvais pas de solution j'avais beau
avoir fui puis un jour je pars dans un
parc avec ma femme on avait décidé de
faire une petite randonnée vous savez
vous passez la guérite vous payer
l'entrée un chemin en goudron puis un
parking on dire sans parking un pont
avec un chemin qui longe la rivière
j'avais repéré ce chemin alors on a
commencé à marcher côte à côte
vous savez quand on marche côte à côte
la voix qui vient bien de l'extérieur ne
vient plus d'en face de vous il ya plus
de jugement il ya plus le regard et puis
ces structures et en marchant côte à
côte pied droit pied gauche
quelque chose c'est synchroniser la voix
qui venait d'extérieur n'est résonner à
l'intérieur comme si ça m'ouvre est une
partie quelque chose que je voulais pas
voir et pourtant cette voix commençaient
à pousser à monter la voix de la femme
n'était plus celle de ma femme le temps
avait ralenti
vous savez quand vous êtes complètement
intériorisé à l'intérieur de vous le
temps n'existe plus vous avancez sans
pouvoir percevoir exactement vous êtes
alors je regarde ma montre
ça fait trois heures qu'on marche je dis
à ma femme écoute il va falloir faire
demi tour parce que on va on va pas
retrouver la voiture avant la nuit
alors on a fait demi tour on a continué
à marcher sur ce chemin qui longe la
rivière
mais derrière une problématique je
commençais à avoir peur peur d'avoir
peur que la nuit tombe et que je
retrouve pas 1 voiture alors toutes les
minutes je regardais ma montre en
pensant que j'avais marché dix minutes
et en fait j'avais marché très peu de
temps ce temps a commencé à s'accélérer
la panique a commencé à me prendre et au
bord de cette rivière j'observe derrière
de l'autre côté il ya un pêcheur et il
est là un train de pêcher
alors j'ai dit s'il vous plaît monsieur
une feinte signe de tête je dis monsieur
s'il vous plaît
je dis comment on peut faire pour passer
de l'autre côté unis mais je comprends
pas ce que vous me dites jeudi voudrait
passer de l'autre côté je comprends pas
et dit monsieur je veux passer de
l'autre côté il me répond pourquoi vous
voulez passer de l'autre côté vous y est
déjà
c'est là j'ai compris que j'étais passé
de l'autre côté de la flaque j'avais
traversé l'atlantique quitté mon pays en
pensant que l'herbe était beaucoup plus
verte ailleurs alors qu'il suffisait que
j'arrose à l'intérieur de moi que c'est
pas mon pays que j'ai fui c'est une
partie moi que j'ai refoulé rejeté cette
partie d'anti terre qui n'avait pas le
droit de prendre du plaisir de s'amuser
alors j'ai commencé à réfléchir à une
chose cette chose profonde cette
solitude qui me donnaient des indices
avaient une perception mais cette
perception
je ne pouvait l'apercevoir qu'avec mes
lunettes la façon où j'observe la vie
alors un matin la révélation s'est faite
en arrivant à mon bureau grand bâtiment
deux étages grandes baies vitrées
parterres de fleurs puis là il ya un
gars avec une pelle il fait des trous
dans la terre 7 heures du matin je
m'approche il a des boîtes en fer un
coté et il fait des trous dans la terre
il met la boîte en fer il recouvre
intrigué je m'approche et puis je me
rends compte que les boîtes en fer cd
toaster des grille-pain je discutais moi
monsieur qu'est ce que vous faites une y
voyez bien je plante des toasters
ok et pourquoi si vous plantez les
toasters monsieur même si ça fait fuir
les éléphants et ça marche
il me répond ben est ce que vous voyez
des éléphants
la perception de la vie sa perception à
lui il avait raison il y avait pas
d'éléphant alors j'ai commencé à
réfléchir sur ma perception de la vie
sur toute la perception des gens qui
nous entourent et cette perception est
dû à des croyances des croyances
héréditaire des croyances culturelles
alors pour pouvoir comprendre comment
ces croyances était ancré dans ma
solitude qui me faisait faire des choses
que j'avais plus envie de faire et ben
il fallait reprendre les croyances alors
j'ai cherché des croyances que tout le
monde connaît savez il ya une croyance
qui est très particulière que vous
connaissez tous
un chat un chat quand il tombe il
retombe toujours sur ses ouais il
retombe toujours sur ses pattes ça c'est
une croyance on la connaît tous et puis
on a pu la vérifier
il retombe sur ses pattes alors il ya
une autre croyance qui dit exactement la
même chose
le toast du matin avec le beurre la
confiture ou ce que vous voulez dessus
quand ils vous échappiez retombe
toujours sur le côté beurré ces deux
croyances qui disent la même chose
pourtant si on les met ensemble comment
ça se passe alors j'ai pris mon chat
je lui ai mis la tartine avec le côté
beurré au-dessus attaché d'ouvrir la
fenêtre du quatrième étage
je me suis posé une question si je lâche
le chat qu'elle est la croyance qui est
vrai et ce qui va retomber sur ses
pattes ou sur le côté beurré une
fonctionnant qu'avec ses croyances ses
croyances qui peuvent s'entrechoquent et
qui n'appartiennent qu'à celui qui les a
créées qui les transmet ses croyances
sont de la surface sur ce que nous
sommes
ces croyances ne sont que celui que vous
devez être parce que vous pensez que
vous devez l'être aux yeux des autres
mais ce n'est pas vous même il faut
aller chercher plus loin ce que vous
êtes votre identité
comment y accéder comment le comprendre
tout simplement ça c'est un autre soir
en rentrant chez moi et il fait nuit
noire sur le trottoir il ya un homme qui
est complètement paniqué je vois
chercher sur le trottoir un vieux
monsieur sous un lampadaire je
m'approche de lui je dis monsieur qu'est
ce qui vous arrive il dit j'ai perdu mes
clefs de voiture
majid inquiétez pas je vais vous aider
je cherche trottoirs caniveaux en herbe
et là je me pose vous savez cette
question idiote compose à tous ceux qui
ont perdu quelque chose savaient cette
question est ce que tu es sûr que tu les
as perdu ici tes clés s'ils savaient où
les avait perdus il les aurait pas perdu
sa salaires idiot mais sa réponse a été
encore plus surprenante il m'a dit non
c'est pas ici que j'ai perdu mes clés
c'est là-bas après le lait mais julie
mais pourquoi vous chercher ici si vous
avez perdu près de la n10 basque ici il
ya de la lumière
on a tendance à aller chercher dans
cette lumière dans nos croyances
on cherche pas ce défi on laisse pas
cette partie non cette partie qui s'est
coincé dans cette solitude capable de
faire des liens notre cerveau et la
poste à chaque fois qu'il trouve quelque
chose votre partie consciente veut
toujours faire mieux que celui qui sait
faire se lancer des défis
sa gelée compris en allant dans un jeu
vous savez ces jeux à la mode
ça s'appelle des jeux des jeux d'évasion
vous connaissez ça vous rentrez dans une
caisse il ya quelqu'un d'assez vicieux
derrière qui ferment à clé ou ait pu
ressortir vous avec une possibilité de
sortir cette pièce c'est avec un code
sur la porte de passer dans une deuxième
pièce une troisième pièce est à chaque
fois un code pour en sortir
le code il est dans la salle dans des
affiches algorithmes des éprouvettes des
tiroirs ce que vous voulez dans cette
salle il ya la solution pour sortir bien
sûr consciemment nommer les meilleurs on
va trouver la solution et puis au bout
d'un certain temps ça commence à se
compliquer on voit le temps passer et on
a tout essayé mais vous savez ce qui
construit ces jeux est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils vont vous apporter une
solution simple très souvent c'est des
tortures et du bulbe ils vont les
chercher au plus profond pour vous
empêcher de sortir d'aller au plus
profond d'eux-mêmes d'avoir ses
capacités de transformer des stratégies
d'aller chercher tout ce que vous avez
pu faire avant pour pouvoir l'emmener le
lier le comprendre se lancer un défi en
mettant de la lumière à l'intérieur
soit c'est ce que j'ai fait contacter
cette partie qui sait cette solitude
elle me fait comprendre une chose
cette solitude elle a fait comprendre
que dans cette société dans cette vie il
ya des gens qui ont tout compris qui
veulent nous rendre la vie très facile
et on va les suivre sans savoir
exactement où on va mettre tout le monde
le faire on va faire pareil on va
refuser notre identité simplement pour
être l'autre cette banque a la capacité
d'offrir à tout le monde tous ceux qui
sont inscrits dans cette banque 86400
sur votre compte tous les jours à minuit
86400 placer sur votre compte
il ya des règles vous n'avez pas le
droit de transférer sur un autre compte
vous avez l'obligation de dépenser vos
86400 tous les jours car à minuit tout
est remis à zéro pour être reversé 86400
le lendemain et puis il ya une autre
règle très importante cette banque
s'autorise à couper votre compte à
n'importe quel moment n'importe quel
instant génial n'est ce pas c'est donc
vous êtes tous c'est la banque de la vie
vous avez 86400 secondes par jour
demandez vous ce que vous voulez en
faire est ce que vous voulez être celui
que vous pensez vous devez être ou si
vous avez le droit de vous autoriser à
être ce qui vous êtes
cette partie elle est là elle vous a
jamais abandonné
c'est vous qui l'avait abandonné si vous
n'êtes pas satisfait de ce que vous êtes
en train de vivre
vous n'avez pas le droit de laisser
cette percussion à l'intérieur entre une
identité qui veut se faire reconnaître
et la perception des autres qui vous
indiquent ce que vous devez être la
solitude a cette capacité de pouvoir
venir pour trouver toutes les solutions
à toutes vos questions même en question
vous ne vous êtes pas encore posée
la solitude est votre amie elle vous
prévient un ennemi vous frappe avant
elle vous préviens cette solitude peut
vous appeler à n'importe quel moment
pour vous donner une solution à lundi
s'est d'ailleurs excusé moi là quelque
chose à me dire
elle est toujours de bon conseil il est
en train de me dire qu il était temps
que je vous remercie
je vous remercie de m'avoir offert 900
crédit de votre journée aujourd'hui et
elle me dit surtout n'oubliez pas fait
confiance à cette partie qui sait merci
[Applaudissements]